what does it mean to grow up in the
middle of a pandemic
it still has to be a time of learning
experimenting and discovering
it's just not as it once was school
isn't the same
forming friendships is different now too
the kind of childhood
young people now have will shape their
adult lives
socially and economically how to best
prepare them
[Music]
it's obviously not the same for children
everywhere but some of them are lucky
digital offerings allowed them to keep
learning virtually during school
closures
however it's not a system without flaws
as one family here in germany has found
out
this berlin family is using smartphones
and flip charts as they try to organize
daily school life during the coronavirus
pandemic
using messaging services like what's up
video games and education apps
it's an unusual situation for both
parents and children
of course we have concerns our biggest
fear is that they will become dependent
that they won't be able to stop playing
or watching videos we're also worried
about content what games and apps they
use
the family has imposed rules every
evening the mobile phones have to be put
away
also the children may only install apps
once their parents have freed access
using the parental control function time
using the phone is limited to two hours
the parents also monitor this using an
app because of digital learning the
eldest daughter was often online for
lengthy periods
at times i found it a bit annoying to be
stuck at my computer the whole day
or half the day i was home alone for
lengthy periods because my parents
weren't there and my siblings were in
emergency
but it was good not to have to walk all
the way to school
and i could sleep in until 7am
her sister first started using a
smartphone during the coronavirus crisis
julius hassamer teaches courses for
young adults on how to use smartphones
and other digital tools
in his experience children can learn a
lot this way
i think it's more important that parents
try to understand rather than prohibit
if you know what your children are doing
on the internet what they might be
afraid of
what they don't understand and what
confuses them then they can better
understand what their children want
what motivates them and lead them in
productive ways
the family has discovered a cooking app
today vegetarian burritos with guacamole
are on the menu
but no smartphones at the table during
the meal
today's school children will eventually
grow up and face adult-sized problems
perhaps bigger than the ones we've ever
known have a look
vast suns are being spent to bail out
ravaged economies
hundreds of billions of euros in germany
in india
in china and in the united states
trillions governments have to borrow
most of this money
but who will pay the debt back today's
elderly
or today's young
much public debt only comes due decades
later
that means today's young will carry the
can in many countries
there's already a shortage of jobs and
training opportunities
higher taxes and spending cuts are quite
likely in the future
so are today's millennials the main
losers in the coronavirus crisis
[Music]
not necessarily they might also stand to
benefit
if investment is focused on shaping the
future
education digitalization
environmental protection
if firms are kept going through the
crisis jobs should become available
again
holders of government bonds should
eventually get paid out
today's young will inherit public debt
but some of them will also inherit
government bonds
so members of the same generation will
be paying
each other back
if an economy grows strongly repaying
debt won't be a huge
problem protracted crises by contrast
would be a disaster
inflation bankruptcies mass unemployment
would be much
worse for coming generations than
inheriting a pile of public debt
professor ludga verseman is the director
of the efo center for the economics of
education and he joins us
now professor vestman you're currently
researching on the effects of the
coronavirus crisis on the younger
generation
are you worried about the current lack
of classroom education for many school
children
yes i certainly am so worldwide more
than one and a half
billion school children are affected by
the school closures
um they are meant to do their schoolwork
at home right now but we
actually know very little about how
that's working i mean how many of the
children have
regular online instruction or how many
are just left on their own
uh for germany we have just done a major
study where we
uh surveyed more than a thousand parents
about how their children were actually
spending the time during the school
closures what we learned is that the
time that span
students spent on school actually half
during that during the corona times 38
of students in germany studied for at
most two hours per day during the school
closures uh
three quarters for at most four hours
they actually spent much more time on on
tv
on on computer games and mobile phones
that increased from four hours to much
more than five hours
now weaker students were particularly
affected and replaced learning with
passive activities we also asked what
the schools were actually doing during
those times and actually
45 percent of students even in germany
never had any shared online lessons
during those times only six percent had
it on the daily basis
and even less often that students have
individual contact with their teachers
and that of course is not a very good
way to learn
it's not a good way to learn as you say
and can you already tell us what kind of
hit to the economy we will experience if
today's children
don't receive the kind of comprehensive
education and training they will need
later on
well research has shown that the basic
skills of the population
are probably the most important
long-term determinant of economic growth
of a country and therefore of the
the prosperity of a society you can use
these
empirical facts that you have to project
out future growth
and if you assume that the currently hit
student cohorts
like just 12 cohorts get a loss
due to the corona induced school
closures of about a third of a school
year's learning
and then actually assume that everybody
afterwards returns back to normal
then even such a scenario would yield a
total economic loss
of more than one percent of future gdp
so this is not just a one-time loss as
we currently have in our economies but
this is going to be staying there
forever
this means several trillion dollars for
most major economies
today's skill school children are of
course tomorrow's workforce
and they'll be saddled with paying off
the billions and pandemic era debt that
their countries have incurred
in order to safeguard their economies so
firstly they already saw their prospects
worsened when they were young
only to have to shoulder this debt into
adulthood what do you think that will do
to society
if you lose a third of a school year of
learning
then this is generally associated on
average with an income loss in the
future of about three to four percent
on average but then again over the
entire working life so
it would really mean that the the
individual students who are hit right
now
will uh just on average have maybe less
prosperous will be uh doing not as well
as if they would have gotten a normal
education is there any way to head off
these negative outcomes for young people
i think we have to try to do everything
to enable children to learn again
and right now really so wherever it's
possible if the virus situation allows
it
we should try to open up schools where
this is not feasible
schools really need to switch to online
teaching right away
it is important that the kids are not
left on their own again
and teachers have to explain the
material and check how the kids are
doing
we have to make sure that we make up the
lost material
we should focus particularly on the
basic skills that are the foundation for
additional learning and to make schools
even better in the future
more effective in helping kids to learn
and i think we need to provide
particularly additional support for the
week students
professor ludgar russman of the ifo
center for the economics of education
thanks for your insights
to your questions now and our science
correspondent derek williams
can you tell us more about dexamethasone
dexamethasone is one of the drugs that
doctors now prescribe
at that critical stage of covid19 that i
just
mentioned when the immune system has
gone into overdrive and starts
attacking healthy tissue in the body uh
a major study in britain that's still
in peer review discovered that in
critically ill patients
who need respiratory support the
compound
lowers mortality by between a fifth
and and a third which is actually pretty
huge dexamethasone is what's known as a
corticosteroid and
it's widely used to treat many different
conditions that cause
painful or dangerous inflammation
it's also an immunosuppressant so
it can help calm down the immune system
when it's
running a mock but that also makes
doctors wary
about about giving patients the drug too
early when the immune system needs to be
active
uh it's it's not a new drug but one
that's been approved for use for for
well over 50 years now
so so it's cheap it's widely available
and perhaps most importantly a
production of it can be can be ramped up
[Music]
quickly
you